i like smoking weed you know what's cool
about smoking weed
it make you think about [ __ ] you
normally wouldn't think about like i was
sitting around house so they smoking
weed
and i got to thinking is it possible for
a male [ __ ]
i got to be higher to be thinking about
midges he said is it possible for a male
[ __ ] to have a real big dick
like i ain't no no geisha but everything
on the [ __ ] be tiny you ever see their
fingers they look like them little
orange baby carrots
like could a [ __ ] actually have some
[ __ ] like this
and i actually know famous [ __ ] people
like i'm good friends with lil webster i
got his number on my cell phone i don't
know why but i got the [ __ ]
and i was hanging out with lil webster
one time and he told me some [ __ ] that
blew my mind
he says when he has sex he don't like
[ __ ] women his size
he liked the [ __ ] normal sized women and
i was sitting around house smoking weed
and i got thinking if lou webster was
[ __ ] a grown-sized woman doggy style
is he actually standing up in the bed
like you get a woman on all fours on the
mattress your feet flat is he standing
straight up in the mat
like if you walked in on some [ __ ] like
that your instinct would be to leave
but you'll check that [ __ ] out for a hot
second but you walk in like oh [ __ ] i'm
sorry
[ __ ] look at this this is crazy no he's
standing on a nike shoe box i can't
believe this
and i don't think we value midgets
enough i think we take them for granted
because i don't give a [ __ ] how bad your
day is you see a [ __ ] you perk up
because when you leave your house you're
not guaranteed to have a [ __ ] sighting
you're not guaranteed
how often do you leave your house and
spot a [ __ ] it's rare
you could be having the worst day in the
world you see a [ __ ] you're like oh
[ __ ] and when there is a [ __ ] sighting
it's always one you've never seen a pack
of midgets you've never seen that
i remember one time i saw 15 midgets
walking down the street
i had a taste for hot wings all of a
sudden
they liked the little drumette piece
they like the smaller okay
i remember i told that joke one time
there was an actual [ __ ] in the crowd
he got pissed off he said some [ __ ] [ __ ]
my whole night up he was like [ __ ]
watch your nuts i was like what
like i've had to watch my back a few
times but i have never had
to watch my nuts i was scared i went
straight on
my girl was like i thought you was with
your boys i said [ __ ] told me watch my
nuts
i'm serious i filed the police report
and everything i'm like he about this
high
he had on oshkosh pagash
and a little propeller hat the
[ __ ] nipped me on the way it was
terrible
i don't know just be a good person what
about that just be nice to people you
know
yeah like a lot of it doesn't add up i
can't keep track of all the rules
like transgender what do you think
that's how i feel i don't give a [ __ ]
you want to go for a man a woman go nuts
well go labia
what's the beef look it's weird to hate
someone because they're trans right but
it's also weird to love someone because
they're trans
shouldn't you like them based on who
they are as a person content to the
character people are so phony i love
caitlyn jenner why
she sucks
she's against gay marriage ran over a
person what's the good part
and they go well they have hard lives
all right well so do bidgets
why don't you talk about how much you
like them where's that hashtag i don't
see any tweets about midgets
who's got a heart at a minute hard to
get around hard to drive hard to get
work no love and look i'm not anti-trans
but i am pro-midge
i just don't get why we help one group
but not another it's just kind of trendy
and people say well trans aren't allowed
everywhere well you're being a roller
coaster
[Music]
at least trans we accommodate with the
bathrooms midgets ever seen how tall a
toilet is
imagine having a jump to take a dump
weird no help no support
and you know what's great about midgets
i got a couple [ __ ] friends they're
good eggs
you never see a [ __ ] complaining never
every other group complains
never a [ __ ] never see it on the news
sitting at a desk legs dangling little
fish
never every other group complains i see
women on news we have a glass ceiling
midget's like you're worried about the
ceiling
holy [ __ ] i'm trying to [ __ ] with this
counter baby
interesting see i guess i'm too
open-minded because i support all
transition not just sexual why do we
stop at sexual i support transition to
personality transition of uh
opinion right like kevin hart kevin hart
got in trouble with some offensive
tweets from years ago
i'm not the same guy i was from years
ago i've transitioned i used to have sex
with 16 year olds
when i was 16. now i don't i'm different
well years ago he said some offensive
stuff well years ago she won the men's
relay people
change why do you support that and not
that
huh it just tells me if i ever get into
trouble now i'm just going to get a sex
change because you got to kiss my ass
hey mark we heard that interview from 10
years ago that was mark
i'm margaret
i don't know i support kevin hart also
because he's a [ __ ]
oh there we go you're writing a book
yes how to be a model yes the complete
idiot's guide to getting into modeling
so like rule number one
be incredibly beautiful i mean what are
the things that you can do rule number
two yeah
don't be a [ __ ] okay
hey that's the new status symbol the
rich people love midges
if you notice that no entourage is
complete now unless you have a [ __ ]
you gotta have a [ __ ]
and you know what that's good for
midgets
that's good for those people because
historically they have not gotten good
jobs
even when they book a movie they never
get to be the hero they always got to
play like a troll
or a fairy running out from under a
bridge
biting on somebody's ankle
it's horrible i feel [ __ ] bad for
midgets
i still call them midges too i know
you're supposed to call them little
people now
i think that sounds worse don't you it's
like you're a little person yes you are
does the little person want to come up
on the big stage
i like [ __ ] but what's wrong with
[ __ ] that's a good word it's a tough
word
my [ __ ] mission yeah
[ __ ] that's political correctness out
of control
there was no reason to change [ __ ]
[ __ ] wasn't a racial slur
right [ __ ] weren't dragged here from
another country forced to do cartwheels
in a circus
it's just a word that's a table that's a
chair and you're a [ __ ]
there's no hatred there
no they're [ __ ] they're irritating
i'm really sick of midgets
no they think you see i don't know who
the [ __ ] is leading the midgets okay but
the dude
he's not doing a good job see they're
changing their names because they're
trying to get us to stop laughing at
them
and they think if they you know it's
like dude you got to get a real [ __ ]
job
they just don't want to work they're
always on trampolines
i'm always jumping out of 50 of their
friends running around always playing
circus
get a real [ __ ] job get off of it get
off of the trampoline get into a cubicle
get some sort of customer service [ __ ]
then yeah
get a suit run around like a [ __ ]
clown all the time
[Laughter]
what a ridiculous thing to be mad about
i'm getting sick of these [ __ ] magics
rick you'll be pleased to know we've
already had some responses and uh simon
and mark have already emailed us in this
link to something that was on the bbc
news website i don't know if you're
familiar with this but it's a remarkable
story
lion mutilates 42 midgets in cambodian
ring fight
that's just a headline that's a hell of
a headline that makes me want to know
more about yeah
that's what a headline should do
spectators cheered as entire cambodian
[ __ ] fighting league
squared off against african lion tickets
had been sold out three weeks before the
much-anticipated fight
the fight was organized when an angry
fan contested
yang shimoni president of the cmfl
claiming that one line could defeat his
entire league of 42 fighters
well the fight was ended rick after only
12 minutes
after which 28 of the [ __ ] fighters
were declared
dead right while the other 14 suffered
severe injuries including broken bones
lost limbs and
they were basically unable to fight the
lion wasn't hurt it would have seemed
that the line was okay oh
good well that's amazing carl what are
your thoughts instantly i mean you're
going to have a take on that
see what's annoying me is i've sent
money to cambodia because apparently
they're hungry
and haven't got any energy so what's
going on well
it's much easier to to fill up a [ __ ]
than it is a regular cambodian
you know they they're actually being
cheated a bit